after 28 years in Angola Ashanti
witherspoon his parole within a week he
travels home to Chicago to be with his
family and this is gonna be the first
time seeing my mother since 1986 and a
number of other relatives since 1971 no
my daughter was actually born three
months after I was incarcerated
but we maintain a close communication
all the years that I was locked up you
know so I've never had a chance to spend
one day in society with her so this is
gonna be a fantastic christmas holiday
does it booty still have a Illinois
Central yeah yeah okay does that look at
all the way they got Domini I mean it
got a shopping center I'll be oh yeah
bowling alley recent hang out they had
on the cotton I'm in the coffee cups
writing off the club all right it's not
Danny more love
I'm doing your skin look all different
how does it look different it look a
little fresher that isn't smooth yeah
i'm so happy that sound my daughter and
my brother and my mother oh you look so
good all right want everybody everybody
look at the camera and weave in the
camera
now a free person ashanti finally
fulfills an old wish the first thing I
want to do when I get I don't want to
take a bath I know that might sound
strange between their little small
things that you missed by being
incarcerated that you remember that
brought you so much joy when you were
younger and I like to go out I mean I
like to take a bow like to sit down on
the bathtub cuz soak in the bathtub
Justin journals just just sit there for
a while but once I got out I realized it
I didn't just want to take a bath I
decided I want to take a bath in the
same bathtub that I used to take it in
when i was a child i send my mother's
home today on december the 22nd 1999
today I'm taking my first bath in 28
years